[Music]
welcome to strategic ideas class
Sinquefield cup style and also as you
all know you at home and in here
tomorrow is my birthday and slightly
more importantly for the Sinquefield cup
Saturday is Rex's birthday so I think
we're the same age anyway I forgot
because I was born a long time ago I
want to talk about the Hedgehog today
because that seems like a strategic idea
I talked about it a little bit in the
beginners class because I was playing
golf and and if you could talk about a
beginner what golf and right is that
good that just the right person okay so
it's not like he just won the tall
memorial although I actually I forgot
let's call him someone Joe how do you do
against envy oh okay anyway so the
reason I want to talk about this this
opening is because it's very strategic
so it's good for that and I had two
hedgehogs in the Michigan Open which I
just finished and my student Matt Larson
when he plays the Hedgehog he loses all
of his games and he hates the Hedgehog
so I only lost one game I didn't was all
my games now the Hedgehog is sort of a
pawn structure you can get from several
different openings now those of you who
know calm ski and Ray Robson well first
I'd say ten minutes out to disarray
right now okay
calm skin ray Robster the US
Championship either this year or last
year I don't remember that in this
position who remembers what calm ski
played I guess it was last year not this
year you right but that's not what I'm
talking about yeah last year what did he
play in this position of this shocking
move he played b6 okay
yeah very suspicious and the game ended
in a draw and they played this year in
the game ended in a draw so I guess I'll
James end in a draw you can actually get
head track type positions from almost
every opening now one of the first
hedgehogs is not well known was played
by white and that was the game
I think it was Fisher off Anderson and
Fisher was white and played the Hedgehog
with white somehow he won a really nice
game he played King H wanna rip g1 and
mated him awesome
okay find that game it's from the early
70s maybe late 60s
yeah 68 to 72 was somewhere in there
okay now the first game a head-to-head
chod was in round 419 play round four
round five was round four for me I took
a bite and my opponent was Alexander
Dietrich and I have a very funny
Alexander Dietrich story and nobody on
YouTube will tell me I'm making fun of
anybody even though I am because they
don't know who he is
Alexander Dietrich is sort of like cliff
Clavin from from Cheers
sort of like a know-it-all but doesn't
know anything but he's very young this
was when he was like 8 so I would be
teaching a chess camp in Michigan and he
was rated 900 maybe and I would show
again he excuse me Grand Master final
that was even a Grand Master then isn't
this similar to the game Stein it's
somebody from 1870 and I'm like what and
he would always be right isn't this this
game and ISM didn't he play this way and
I'm like what and he did this every time
he knew everything he was always right
though and I'm like why is he 900 he
knows everything and now he's 2100 but
like 4 years later but he knew
everything ok and then the reason I'm
telling this story is out of the Chicago
up and I had my usual bad tournament and
I had to give a ride home to national
tournament director Glenn panner who's
also an expert at chess and on the way
home he said there was this guy in the
tournament and he was telling me the
sign says the legal amount of people in
this room is 175 by the fire marshal but
there's 800 here and he was yelling at
me and I was like wait a minute
was this Alexander Dietrich and he's
like yeah so I all I knew is that he
complained about the sign I knew was
Alexander Dietrich even though there was
a hundred people there because then he
explained to him there were things cut
it you know that it wasn't one room it
was suffer
yeah okay so this guy's a stickler right
he's you know theory and write good
notes and steinitz and there's too many
people in this room so this guy knows he
knows what he's doing he doesn't he
doesn't just like play random moves and
helps it it's the area this guy knows
what he's doing so I'm playing Alexander
Dietrich now last year I also played
Alexander Dietrich and I was a drawing
position and he blundered I won tried to
get my revenge for him having a drawn
position in his ratings about 2100 and
he's approximately 14 years old
within a year either way yes yeah okay
and Alexander played c4 okay and I
played c5 and we did we did some of this
stuff okay and he played g3 and then all
just g6 and all kinds of yeah Bishop g7
castles now this is technically not a
hedgehog so that's why I won technically
but it has the same ideas okay take
stakes now this is an English
symmetrical English and in a hedgehog
black is always seeing cuddling is his
bishop on b7
okay and sometimes black fiend cattles
his bishop and sometimes he doesn't for
the real super hedgehog positions you'll
see the game that I lost and this
position I analyzed with Gregory Qaeda
knov before anybody was born including
me and Gregory so was analysis was a
little iffy and we looked at the move
Knight g4 because that was maybe the
fifth most common move maybe the fourth
and we did a lot of analysis but since
it was 20 years ago I don't remember
much of it but I played it several times
most of my opponents think forever here
they're like what Knight g4 now Knight
g4 obviously attacks this now when I say
Hedgehog the people who were sticklers
or the the main stickler left Alex
Marlar
he would say this isn't a hedgehog
because you did a feeding kettle your
Bishop and your pawns on the third rank
but the ideas are very similar White has
a space advantage white steam covetous
King Bishop and white stopping d5 so
black has very little play but black
gets to move around and be solid and
eventually trick white although this
game was much trickier than that and so
well I'm attacking his knight okay so he
played III which i think is the best
move and he's attacking my knight and I
played d6 defending my knight very
strange chest and I'm sacrificing a pawn
which I've had a couple people accept
but I mean they end up losing I think
taking the pawn is actually bad I think
like it's too much play on the diagonal
and the B file and the bishop is on c6
which is terrible my opponent played b3
which i think is a good move and he's
good at fee and kinda was Bishop and a
normal Hedgehog style I would have to
fee and kind of my Bishop which is
virtually impossible here
so I played Queen to a5 I'm sorry I
played 95 and he played h3 and again
nobody does anything and waits for the
other the strategic idea here for both
sides is you can't do anything so when
you eventually do something it's going
to be bad so I'm going to protect
everything and for specially true for
Wyatt White's protecting everything in
his position if you look at all of these
squares on the white side of the board
okay they're all protected I can't go
anywhere but I found a square anyway
because there's a lot of squares on the
board so I'd played Queen here now we're
gonna vote because voting is fun and you
will probably do better than my opponent
because he's not here to vote you're
gonna vote to play either Bishop to b2
or Bishop to detail so take a little
time to think about it and then we'll
vote he said as he sipped his Perrier
who votes for Bishop to b2 1 2 3 the
Caribbeans boy who votes for Bishop to D
to carry the votes for both it's 4 to 4
ok so the answer is 9 now my opponent
played want to move out the other move
is better so he's like you guys ok
Bishop deeds who is the correct move
right and now the black queen is quite
stupidly placed I might add in fact I
think the computer wants me to play
Queen d8 but yeah my queen is just
terrible on a5 and he'll play rook C 1
and so forth Queen e2 and it's hard for
black to do anything
he played Bishop to b2 and he's higher
rated than all of you so ok
he played Bishop to b2 ok now my queen
can stand a 5 as long as it wants it
turned out it didn't want to stay there
very long
now one idea that black has of this
opening is to change the pawn structure
so we can attack Knight takes d4 which I
played and Knight to c6 and now I'm
attacking the pawn and my opponent
played 92 which is fine other moves are
also fine any defends his pawn again
black is trying to get active play and I
played Queen h5 and he thought for a
long time and I think it was the Harz V
lecture I think it was Ronan pretty sure
was Ronan and he said something correct
so right away I was like wow because
I've I've watched a lot of lectures in
chess and I've seen some funny ones
Ronan says a lot of things that are
correct so I'm always like really
shocked and Rona usually when you get
advice in chess books you just if you
want to get better at chess you should
throw the book out but in this instance
relevant was right on the money me and
did he say it right he said the longer
you think the more you don't know what
you're doing you think 20 30 40 minutes
on a move your moves
good it's like we moved in that good and
then that and then I was like yeah that
guy's right and not what just with me
but with my opponents when they think
twenty thirty forty minutes their moves
not gonna be any good there's a reason
why they're thinking thirty forty
minutes they don't they can't find a
good move and they don't understand
what's going on so they just sit there
and I've done that a lot I thought
thirty forty minutes and I make a dumb
move and that's exactly what my opponent
did here he thought at least twenty
minutes and the move I was worried about
wouldn't occur to any of you especially
Joe who already told okay
and the thing is if I play Bishop takes
h3 which is the threat which I would do
if it was my move he could play Knight
f4 for K might Queen and Bishop however
I could then play Queen takes Queen so
if his queen wasn't there I can't play
Bishop takes h3 so actually the mean was
I was looking at where Queen d2 and
Queenie one queen deeds who I was gonna
play Bishop h6 I think and Queenie one I
think I was gonna play g5 or maybe
Bishop h6 I can't take as of Knight f4
anyway a very reasonable move would be
Knight f4 okay good move now my opponent
played a bad move the kind of move
low-rated players like to play and
that's why I'm higher rated than them
because they play moves that aren't as
good and this move weakens everything
and when you move pawns in front of your
king and your King has no protection
then things like what happened to this
game happen in this game and he played
g4 and there was a twenty minute think
then I played this and he then thought
again because the move he was planning
on playing he decided it was bad his
intention he told me after the game was
f4h v g5 Bishop takes h3 Bishop f3 and
my queen is trapped and he forgot that
his rook was attacked he's like that
Queen can't move I'm gonna win that
Queen eventually maybe Bishop c3 d1 now
I'm not convinced that he's a hundred
percent wrong maybe if I take the rook
he
takes back with the queen and my queen
is trapped but once he saw this he's
like that I'm not doing this I don't
want to lose all this material
exchanging upon and hope to win his
Queen later and I didn't well when I
looked this with my computer it did not
suggest these moves for why it doesn't
like white in this variation so now
after my response that he expected he
completely changed his mind so that 20
minutes things did a lot of good
although for me and once again he you
know the sort of goes on tilt like just
sort of like playing super aggressive
crazy
he played e5 he did play d5 that would
hang his Bishop he played Bishop c3 that
would not hang his Bishop and I played
up five and I'm activating my rook I'm
attacking this pawn he doesn't want to
take and what my piece is out so you
played f3 and his Bishop is a little
iffy and to keep it if he I played f4
now it sort of stays there again he
should slowly but surely extricate his
position with Bishop II one kicking my
queen out then probably Bishop f2
defending his pawn move these two pieces
and play Bishop f1 and get his Bishop
back in the game that's about equal but
blacks pretty happy but again he is you
know trying to play aggressively and
plays d5 giving my knight to square not
good now he decided his knight should go
to this square and if he was playing
blitz chess outside an hour ago he would
have just gone here right Julian okay
but he legally got his [ __ ] not what he
should do again is play Bishop to e1 and
then move his knight there buddy he
played Bishop to g4 so his knight could
do that
then I played h5 because that's where
all my pieces are and he made the losing
move Knight to c3 and now black is
completely winning I take he takes and I
sacrificed my bishop now I have to tell
you I play bridge with the chess master
named West burger
and Wes is not a good bridge player but
he probably used to be a good bridge
player he's a little long in the tooth
now and he was a good chess player he
was 2,300 and when Wes plays bridge if
he does something aggressive that means
you really blundered because he doesn't
do anything aggressive so when he does
then you boy you in trouble that means
you really deserved it
in chess he's sort of similar as Julian
will attest to two boring draws so the
same could be said for me when I
sacrifice the piece man are you in
trouble unless you're Aronian then I
sacrificed six pieces but if I sacrifice
a piece in a slow game that means you're
losing because I don't sacrifice pieces
so when I play Bishop things g4 you're
in a lot of trouble because I don't like
giving my bishop away and he took my
bishop then I'd played Knight takes and
I'm threatening Queen age to checkmate
with advantage and I didn't sack a piece
and threaten mate and then not analyze
it I figured it all the way out what
move would white make that would stop
checkmate because that would be bad if
you got checkmated you I'll wait I got
nothing to do work out three so it's
echo in here now his King has a flight
Square and rook F 3 is the move that I
looked at also good if I wanted to
calculate many many many more variations
was instead of threatening mate to play
f3 right away also a good move which
computer recommended okay what computer
also said this wins
now I played a move which I knew one I
knew I won material I knew I was meeting
him but even better was to play Queen h2
and 93 Chuck and he has to take what's
bishop and I take and even though I'm
down a piece I'm threatening Bishop
takes Knight
I'm also threatening where takes rook
and if Bishop takes I have Queen F to
mate and if Queen takes rip to f8 wins
is Queen and I'm threatening the night
and
pinned so he's incredibly lost computer
says I'm up between six and seven okay
but I couldn't find this because I was
all sixes and sevens right Ken West the
only person ever heard that phrase okay
so I played something that I knew one
that didn't win as much I've only plus
two point seven terrible
I played Bishop takes check and then I
played check and then I played I III
because now Bishop takes Knight is
illegal due to the fact that there's no
Bishop there so rook takes Knight should
be illegal because pawn takes check and
then man you don't have white here cuz
bad stuff is gonna happen when I take
that so he must play King e2 then I take
with check and rook f2 and when I
sacrificed a piece I saw this position
and noticed I was up two pawns and that
I have a knight here and his king is
running around like God's good position
and I checked and he moved his King and
I played Queen to f5 and he didn't want
me to play Queen c2 so he played Knight
to e4 I attacked his rook
he saw it I attacked his rook again he
saw it and now I played for a trick a
very hard trick to see unless your
computer then it's very easy but if
you're human it's not easy computer
doesn't like my move because it sees my
trick and then it stops it and says I'm
winning but not as winning as before my
opponent had about a minute left to make
five or six moves so I didn't think he
would see my trick somehow I was right I
played Queen h3 which looks like it
threatens Knight f3 check because it
does threaten night after a check but
yeah so he should play rib to g1 and
then if I play Knight f3 which I
wouldn't do he would take it and then
take on g6 and he has a winning attack
probably so rook G ones the best move
when I was going to play rook f5 but my
opponent saw Knight f3 but didn't see my
other three
so he played rook to f1 I didn't think
he'd see my this right I was right in my
moves till win so it's not terrible and
I played my next move and my opponent
resigned immediately without letting me
hit the clock even very nice of him
waste my time hitting the clock
so this move actually sets up a
combination of three consecutive forks
so I fork then I fork the next move and
then I fork the next move Ken West is
enthralled Julian I play Queen III and
he resigned which was best notice his
king and queen er attacked so Queen
takes Queen is forced I Fork again so
King takes bonus force and then I fork
again and I get a ruck and I have a rook
at upon for a knight and unless you're
Edward Lasker did you actually get that
I broke it up on B tonight now that none
of you anybody at home you got it
really nice there was a famous game
between Laster and Lasker I think it was
Dustin Hoffman the Meryl Streep and it
was rook and pawn versus night and there
was nothing else on the board but it was
a draw I think it was New York 24
Julian's like yeah just say yes yeah New
York 1924 yeah I mean obviously and he
resigned because there's so many pieces
on the board by Rick and passed Palm
Hotel okay so that was not a hedgehog
but it was close it was almost a
hedgehog now I also played in round two
of this event on going backwards in time
and actual hedgehog incredible and this
is actually very strange I've never seen
this in my life in round one of an open
tournament which had 34 players so one
plays eighteen two plays 19 and so forth
in the open section the lower rated
players won they won Laurita player
scored more than the higher rate of
pliers I've never seen that happen and
in round one I played in 1906 and around
- I played in 1900 because all the
players won they be diary 2 players they
got A+ score now I'm bored too
the gentleman that I played in round 2
was on board to the previous round I was
watching his game and he's getting
crushed and then he was down material
and his opponent was 2250 and but he won
I don't I don't know how he won I didn't
see so so he won yeah if you were rated
2200 this tournament you lost a lot of
rating points then with like three guys
and they always drew and went home
crying so I didn't play any of them
because they all lost all their games
now this guy played actual Hedgehog he
played b6 or I did and I actually had
two real edge hogs this tournament I'm
like the fake ones from the other
tournament night here here seven I know
he played me for very early but not here
I think as I'm transposing so well I'll
get to that I'll get to the Hedgehog
position since I can't remember how we
got to it but and he played Queen d2 I
apologize he didn't fee and kind of his
King Bishop that's why I couldn't
remember this is what he did the fee
encounter was my last round okay any put
his rooks in the middle and I castled
he played King edge from which I thought
was a bit odd but well I know like c8
this one you see seven all very not too
exciting and this structure is very
interesting because both sides have to
figure out what their opponent wants to
do and then not let them do it and it's
not clear what you want to do it's not
so simple now the way they play the
hedgehog now this setup with black
pudding always pawns here there's to
play rook c8 Queen c7 which
I did and then queen bee ate this ship
c7 Bishop d2 c7 and then when you play
d5 on some day in your life you're
attacking h2 and then when you play rook
e8 your rook isn't blocked by the bishop
and sometimes you put your knight on g6
and 25 years ago nobody did this most
people put their Bishop here and
occasionally they were feeding cattle
their Bishop but usually they would just
leave it here nobody thought about lying
the Queen and Bishop up here but you
know I read stuff and I actually did
this once but I didn't play rook c8 and
my rook was on a 8 for 17 months so that
was unfortunate ok now my opponent
played a couple of strange rules he
played here I don't know why he's
retreating ok this is here I'm sorry and
I played this and I was all ready to
play Bishop here Bishop here and he
played Queen e1 oh I'm sorry I played
it's my move here I played rook e8 and
he played Queen e1 and I was ready to
play bishop here bishop hereby thought
we would go to h4 and my bishop should
probably be on this diagonal yeah so
this is actually the correct position so
this is quite strange because generally
you want to put your rook on the same
file as your opponent's Queen so his
rook was here and my queen was here I
moved my queen out of the way that way
no funny stuff what happened my opponent
conversely moved his Queen to the file
of my rook thinking well that files
closed I don't care okay well if the
file is closed and you don't care maybe
I should open that file up so I played
d5 and in the bin the pedrad you want to
play either d5 or b5 and open things up
for your pieces well if his Queen is
here and as other pieces are here
I would like my rook to capture all of
them that I'm the favorite unless I'm
playing Aronian so d5
and computer strangely says it's the
best to move takes takes takes and now
computer wants me to play b5 and like
harass this night and harassed and it
says black is better but I played Bishop
to d6 because I I did what I wanted to
do I'm attacking the pawn I opened my
rook up and my opponent played the
expected move Queen to h4 getting off of
this and defending his pawn and I
assumed when he played Queen e1 he
wanted to play Queen h4 now one thing
that I do that most of you don't do and
that's why I'm slowly higher rated than
most of you LaVon here right okay good
and you're not watching at home are you
LaVon one of the things I do is I
imagine where my pieces can go where
they would be good and then I try to put
my pieces there and then if I get there
I win unless I was wrong to start with
which would be terrible and in this
position since I have two pieces
attacking h2 my queen and my bishop I
wanted to get more pieces attacking h2
and so I played the very unusual move
rook to e5 because I want to play rip to
h5 now if you've watched chess at the
chess club before or watch chess videos
or have followed jenshaw hotties career
you may notice she likes to turn rover
where you move your hook up and over and
you know that happens sometimes maybe
not as often as Jen says what it happens
I'm in fact before Jennifer mentioned
these ideas I had discussions with
Gregory Kai Donovan
the fact that we both like doing that we
like moving our rook up and over both of
us and a friend of mine who's a
relatively new chess student and she's a
friend - she always says send me your
game and send me your game seven your
games so I said in my image and this
tournament she sent me a text and she
says you you like to move your rooks up
but over a lot and I was like I guess
okay and this is an example so I want to
play rook h5 with advantage big
advantage
now g4 is a little suspicious
because you know your king is getting
exposed after f4 I could just move my
rook back and that floor is pretty
weakening or I could play rook takes
Bishop Knight takes rook
this should takes f4 and Ulf Anderson
would be proud of me because I stay
actually exchanged I have all the dark
squares and the Knights pinned and I'm
gonna play rook e8 and queen e5
so this is also fine for black my
opponent played another groove I
analyzed which I thought lost and I was
right which is Bishop f4 and after rook
age five the bishop is hanging and the
Queen is hanging so takes n takes now
this is the beginners class it's not far
from it
then I would not expect anybody to find
the right move here for Wyatt but was
such a fine audience as yourselves can
you find the only move white can play to
avoid immediate loss that would lose the
Queen
so now 94 very good and the idea is you
attack my queen i attack your queen and
if the knight takes the night the night
is no longer defending the rook because
it took the knight and the rook is
hanging and I saw this when I played
rookie 5 and I correctly calculated it
it's never happened before
I took the night he took the rug and I
played 9f to check he played the best
move and I took the rook now White has
two ways to capture the night with the
rook of the bishop with the rook would
be bad because I would take his Knight
so I took with the bishop now I didn't
play the winning move because I didn't
see it
that's a good reason I actually did see
the first move I didn't see the second
movie I saw Queen c5 check King h1 and
now I did not see Queen to b5 which
threatens Queen s1 mate with advantage
and Queen takes b2
also is pretty strong and computer says
I'm winning but I didn't see queen bee
five double attack very nice I saw
something else and I thought it would
happen and I thought it was happening
and then it didn't happen story of my
life but not about chess necessarily
okay so I played queen f4 attacking the
rook the rook moved away I think he went
to a one could have gone to be won to a
one's harder for me to reach so you PI
went there okay
and then I played Knight f6 if you know
what the word plethora means you will
know that white does not have a plus the
rev squares for his queen okay and I'm
positive
even though I don't know what positive
means and if you saw Django that's funny
okay so Knight f6 tagging the Queen and
he moved his Queen here and I had this
all worked out
I played what did I play oh yeah what
did I play that yes I played Queen to d2
had it all worked out and now I thought
the game would end in two moves but it
ended in 2000 was instead I thought I
was threatening Rep takes Knight and
that he wouldn't want me to play that if
he moves his Knight I play Queen e1 maid
I didn't think want me to play that
either so I thought he would defend his
night with well then I would take his
work Queen f5 that's what I expected
then I would play rook e8 threatening
rook e1 which would give checkmate next
move he would stop checkmate let's say
h3 that stops checkmate and then I would
play the move he couldn't possibly see
so this is why I expected the whole time
black to play and went into one move
winning is good because you win if
you're listening at home write that down
this is the winning move it gives black
a big advantage to do the fact that it
wins and this is my kind of move this is
my style
you guys are sacking all your pieces
this is my style retreat's MVL Frenchman
hmm Bishop c8 and now you'll notice the
Queen has nowhere to go
ah so I thought that would happen cuz I
thought he would never see that
and I thought wrong as usual so after
Queen to d2 my opponent picked up his
queen and I was like yes Queen a5 rook
e8 and he played queen g3 and I was like
hmm if I take his Knight tag take Queen
BH I could be annoying and maybe I could
trade Queens but I'm not sure if I'm
winning that endgame this rook comes out
and my king and I was like that might be
winning oh no and I was like all right
this is the worst piece as ever I'm not
gonna trade them all off so I just took
my pawn back now he went back to playing
deadly he was like looking at time to
play badly he played Queen f2 which
isn't the worst move and now he played
the worst move
he played Queen g3 and after Queen f6 he
has some issues down here and well this
reminded me of something
usually when you learn how to play
better chess you see some tactic then
you go to you're getting on a book or an
online or you solve some tactical
puzzles then you go online go online
then you go to your tournament and your
opponent makes this blunder you're like
ah I know this tactic and you win
question no you can't do that if you
could then I would have won yeah then I
could go here but not all the way to
here okay so what was I saying
oh yeah so you're playing a tournament
game and you're like aha I saw this
tactic before and then you win and
you're great
ken westeros I'm talking about anyway
this reminded me of a game that I lost
where I played terribly except my
opponent had that position I was like oh
that's good for me
my opponent plays like I did when I lost
and what it reminded me of that the
bishop on d1 if you're watching at home
and you have a database or you can go
online find the game from the 2012
Chicago open fine gold even Issa vich
and you'll see my bishop on d1 and when
the game ended he was like yeah he was
your went to d1 as st. ain't no good
thank you gonna lose and his rings 26 60
feet a so he's right yeah he crushed me
I'm gonna crush that bad in a while
that's it's like three days ago or an
hour ago
it's throwing okay so when his vision
was on d1 I was like yes that's Bishop
should be on d1 rockin is terrible now
he proceeded to sacrifice all of his
pawns very suspicious yeah I don't know
what he was thinking maybe was thinking
I'm B's
he played Queen e1 when I was like
alright and then he played f4 all right
and then he attacked my Bishop and I was
like I know no I he did not resign this
game
so he attacked my knight but I saw it if
my knight moves away takes my bishop is
he sneaky so I defended by night then he
attacked my pawn and I defended my pawn
then he attacked it again but he's not
really attacking us defended now it's my
turn to do stuff this reminds me of
something quite funny I was reading a
bridge article on bridge which makes
sense was a bridge article and a guy
who's world-class world famous player
was playing with his wife who is not
world class and not world famous she's a
beginner but she wants to play bridge
and the whole night she hadn't done
anything good whenever she was playing
the hand terrible so she bid the hand
and he had the best hand ever he was
like ah ha if I never bid she'll play
the hand and she'll make it and she'll
be happy so he just kept passing even
though he shouldn't do that and the
opponent's wouldn't let her play the
hand they were bidding even though they
couldn't and eventually they got to a
point where he didn't think she could
make anything because it was getting
and he says okay what can I make then he
bid to make all the tricks and he took
all the tricks so if they had shut their
mouth they would have got a good board
but after a while he's like alright
that's enough now it's my turn and
that's what happened here the last
several moves White's been attacking
attacking attacking he's not really
attacking now that's my turn so my turn
is rook takes c2
yeah now I took a piece and all his
pieces are hanging and trapped he still
went no and he so he was in time trouble
he took I took the rook he moves his
King to safety my favorite move was a
game right next to me beautiful
beautiful here and checkmate
and when i checkmated him I didn't say
checkmate because I thought it was
checkmate
so I took the pond I didn't hit the
clock and he picked his king up and I
was like nah that's not going anywhere
and he was like God maybe no but I like
the way my Queens did a little rigmarole
there yeah hooray so so that actually
worked because when I open the position
up with d5 my rook and his queen were
lined up now the first game I showed you
by accident because I'm the greatest
teacher ever
the last game I'm going to show you two
key positions okay
from the Hedgehog from the last round I
had three games that went over five
hours you know what I'm talking about
all your chest games go over five hours
each okay so it's a head jog you see all
my pawns but it didn't work out well
because these are here question that's
correct that happens in the hedgehog
that's part of the lecture and when
they're all lined up then they defend
all the squares he can't go anywhere now
in the hedgehog if you remember the last
game and you don't I play d5 and my rook
and his queen we're here and so forth
well I always want to play d5 because
I'm not playing b5 I'm not doing that
not playing b5
now d5 is bad move because it loses so I
didn't play it here because he takes
with Shaq and I resign I don't want to
take with Shaq so I moved my king that
was to set up g5 he was oblivious that's
why he's the champion and I didn't know
he played g4 and now I still can't play
d5 because if I play d5 and he takes my
bishop and I take woodchuck
and he takes I lose a piece I can't take
his bishop cuz he takes my rook so I had
to make one more preparatory move for d5
and hope he doesn't see it
I played rook to f8 and now I'm
threatening d5 it doesn't look like I'm
threading d5 it looks like I did some of
that action and he didn't see d5 and he
played f5 he was hoping I would play e5
and my bishop is very suspicious so when
I play d5 he was shocked and he thought
for 10 minutes Julian is appalled to the
10 minute think like what 10 minutes and
the idea behind d5 isn't all this
nonsense it's that my bishop is
attacking his bishop he played the best
move Bishop to c1 although every move
was equally good actually I took with
Czech and he took back and now I made a
mistake
after which I'm worse and then I made a
mistake after which I'm lost
yay after making the equalizing move the
correct way to play is to take with
Chuck and then play g6 check I thought
this was bad because he would play King
e6 and start taking my pieces what I
didn't see was Bishop to d6 which looks
like it hangs my bishop but then I play
rook e8 check and his King can't stay on
his rook unless he goes here and gets
checkmated then hitting sin is rock so
he would have to move his King here and
I would play rook takes rook check and I
would have a rook for a bishop so I
would have the advantage and I didn't
see them with Bishop d6 so I thought
this was not playable that was the first
thing that I missed so I played a move
where I'm not equal I'm worse I played
rook takes rook
he played rook takes truck I checked he
took and I played rikiei and this was my
whole point when I played the move d5
and the idea is I'm keeping his King out
if he plays King here which if he had
done that I'd have more money in my
pocket now I would play Bishop 83 check
attacking his Bishop he would play king
f7 I would play check and if he plays
King to g8 I simply take his Bishop he
plays King to f8 I play another
discovered check to discovered checks in
a row and then I win his rook so when I
played rook to e8 I knew that he
couldn't play King to e6 so I was gonna
play g6 check next to move but then I
was like he he has a really good move
here I hope he doesn't see it and of
course he did rook h3 attacking my pawn
if my pawn moves they comes in this way
and then I'm gonna lose some stuff and
now I have a chance to draw but I missed
it because I had 14 seconds on my clock
to make three more moves I should play
g6 bishop d8 check rookie seven check
and then this makes a queen because he
promoted it but that's beginner class
King c6 rook takes pawn and now my rook
can get active and I'm a pawn down but I
have good chances to draw because my
rook is doing really good and I could
play f5 and get a passport or says I'm
slightly worse but probably not losing
but I didn't see any of that so I didn't
do any of that and with seconds left on
my clock I played the terrible move
Bishop f8 and he was like yum-yum-yum
rook take and now I made a much worse
move you'll notice my pawn is pinned and
you'll notice my King is on a dark
square so Bishop f4 check could be
annoying so to stop all of that I could
play king c6 now my pawns not pinned and
Bishop f4 is not check and I'm slightly
losing I'm losing but I might have his
but I played rook e1
attacking his bishop and he attacked my
pawn uh-uh and I can't move my pawn
because it's pinned but I can defend my
pond now my bishops really good this
ship f4 Chuck rook h8 now I'm a pawn
down my King is worse and my pawns are
all in the wrong collar and my bishop
can't move and it's attacked and his
Kings coming in so that worked out
really badly okay now to show you the
end of the game because the end of the
game was cool we got this position the
check check Rick f6 okay and hmm
I'm gonna stay here now I'm gonna stay
here okay and this position I played
rook f5 and this got quite funny I mean
for him he played rugby six check if I
play King c5 I thought he would trade
rooks
Shaq takes take takes and then my pawns
could be attacked by his Bishop and this
pawns queening so I would be losing I
wouldn't have any play I would just lose
so I wanted to keep the rooks on the
board so I could trick him later
what did i trick him I tricked him into
checkmating me hey so well I should
still do that and lose I guess but I
play King d7 and he played rook d7
shucks and this is very annoying because
I have four legal moves and they all get
mated except one the one I don't want to
play if I play king c6 he plays
checkmate with advantage if I play King
a6
he plays Bishop to b8 and rook a7 mate
is annoying if I play King c8 he plays
rook check and rook c5 discovered check
and my rook is hanging I didn't like any
of that so I had to play all the moves
that avoid that King AAA I really hate
that cuz I'm sitting down
terrible okay and he wanted to come meet
me instead of making a queen he came to
meet me
and I thought he would play King here
and King takes pawn and meet me and the
computer wants me to play Bishop here
Bishop III and defend my pawn but I
wanted to win a pawn
so I'd played rook here and work takes
pawn to defend my pawn hey any checked
and being a grandmaster
I played the only legal move and he
checked me again now the obvious move is
King to a6 but I keep getting checkmated
the same way and then wreck a7 checkmate
with advantage so I have to play King to
AAA actually that's not what he did he
played this show to be a check that's
the checkmate if King a6 ripped d7 Rick
a7 mate
so I played King ace AAA now the
computer announces mate and I saw the
mate so I was ready to lose but my
opponent didn't play the mate
so I got to suffer more
he could play c5 and the idea is if I
take he plays Bishop d6 check the ship
c5 check and mate if I don't take the
pawn on c5 and I just make some random
move he plays check and check and rook
here mate so c5 is made computer says
this mates but he didn't do that he
played her g8 and I was like man he
could play c5 next we would meet me
again how do I stop that
so I played Bishop e3 which does stop
that mate and he played Bishop d6 check
I made the only legal move because I'm
good
we're k7 check again if I play King a6
Bishop b8 and rook a 7 mate so I went
back and now he played here
attacking all of my pieces and here I
resigned if I don't resign I have to
take this and he would take and then I
would resign but I guess I could move my
bishop and he would take this and then I
would resign because my can't move my
king and he's getting to Queens he could
play here here here here hard to stop
yeah
also he could Queen that pond or you
could take the a pond yeah and the
computer says minus 35 he's up to pawns
and that's the rough I tells you yeah so
that game took five and a half hours
then I lost and I won the huge prize
which I put on Facebook $26 thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]